from iowa clinton yates columnist for
the undefeated living the baseball dream
he was at the all-star festivities out
in denver and now he gets a little slice
of baseball heaven
out there at the corn game in iowa ben
line's in for rich on the rich eisen
show appreciate you hanging out clinton
are you in heaven right now
uh no i'm behind the plate and there's a
guy with the john deere who's cutting
the grass
yeah i'm definitely in iowa and i'm
definitely looking at the new field at
the old field um i gotta say this
operation i'm trying to get out of this
guy's way he's making much more noise
than i anticipated i gotta say this
operation is pretty wild like
what it takes to build a field and stick
it in the middle of an iowa cornfield
it's not necessarily more than i realize
but like
this building is huge you know what i'm
saying we're talking 400 centers 335 on
each side i mean it's not like this is
some small field there's a big league
field out here so it's been quite the
operation
it's incredible that like you said
they're able to pull this off just from
a logistical standpoint but forgetting
just the the operations of the game the
physical structure is necessary just the
energy of the people the people that
you're getting a chance to interact with
uh what kind of folks are out there for
baseball in iowa
so
they're opening the doors right now so
none of the fans are here yet but i've
been here
i just i got to the park at about 9 00
a.m and one of the things that's funny
is that there's been a lot of rain here
this week so they had like a situation a
lot of rain on a farm means a lot of mud
and they had to like get real ass
farmers back out here to like re-mulch
and make sure that all these production
trucks and all these people could move
about so like i mean i don't want to get
too far off into this talking about you
know game day ops but like you know it's
been pretty impressive to see all these
people working in conjunction with each
other not just mlb but the people around
here to make sure that this operation
can really get off the ground you know
baseball always gets attacked for not
embracing change not embracing the next
younger generation but i look at the
london series that i was fortunate
enough to attend two years ago i look at
what they're doing tonight out in iowa
they're trying they're creating moments
they're doing stuff different i agree
with you man but like don't get it
twisted this is full-blown gimmicky like
you know what i'm saying and not
necessarily in like a bad way like i was
in the yankees dugout earlier and even
the like you know how in a dug out in
the big leagues don't have like the
boxes with the um the like the thera
guns the boxes with the the sunflower
seeds and all that like even those are
in like the faux rusty wood
paneling you know look and i was like oh
wow y'all are really going all the way
with this so like you know there's an
element of kind of theme park type
situation but like it's still pretty
cool because the other field is there as
well but i would imagine being such a
big baseball fan that you are clinton
yates joins us from the undefeated you
got to love this yes it's gimmicky yes
it's kitschy yes it kind of feels like
you're playing baseball at disney world
or something but
how great is this you get to cover the
game of like the field of dreams game as
somebody who's been covering the game
for a long time imagine it feels cool to
be a part of these moments it is very
cool and i appreciate you saying that
like field of dreams as a movie i
realized this because i watched it on
the plane on the way here i'd sort of
forgotten some of the things that were
important to me in that movie and like
people always talk about the dad
connection the emotion of it but they
kind of forget about like there's some
small parts about the baseball that are
really interesting like specifically the
part where they go to fenway park and
he's keeping his scorebook i completely
forgot that the reason why i ever even
started keeping a scorebook at all as a
kid was because i saw kevin costner
doing it in field of dreams that i asked
my dad what is he doing and i didn't
know and he got me a book and said
that's what he's doing you can figure it
out on your own and there's also the
part where when they bring out all the
other players
the chai socks invite their friends and
you've got guys in like different
uniforms from way back in the day like
the story line is one thing but there's
some really intricate details in that
movie that sort of only a big time
baseball fan will really kind of pay
attention to that that makes me like it
you know just sort of the throwback
stuff that we don't we don't really see
anymore it's quite a fun thing and so to
be here walking through the corn ben you
don't understand pretty damn
clinton yates joining the show from the
undefeated hear him on espn la radio as
well giving us dodger updates dodgers
can't seem to have a consistent lineup
they're so lucky they've got so much
talent but now with cody being banged up
and clayton's not getting right after
the all-star break is there a reason to
be concerned in dodger land just about
the health of this team
i mean the health is a problem the depth
is obviously their plus but the clayton
situation the kershaw scenario i'm kind
of worried about because i'm worried
that they're going to find some scenario
by the by i just walked in the press box
in the field so i'm standing at the left
field foul pole right now i just want
your listeners to know that so they can
get a good visual i love it what your
boy is doing i love it um so
the cursor situation is tough because
like that went from like oh yeah kind of
tweaked something not really feeling so
great to uh where's clayton been for a
while to uh it's gonna
do we lose him we lost clinton out in
the outfield lost in the corner
yeah better watch out for malachi he's
turned into a ghost out there
he's now emerged from the cornfield he's
back in this space-time continuum
clinton yates joining the show in the
real world we appreciate you checking
back in with us what's it like to see
the afterlife there in the cornfield i
don't think the baseball gods wanted me
amongst the corn on my phone that was
doing a little bit too much so i don't
know what happened there but i'm back
all right we were talking about the
dodgers let's switch gears and talk
about the other team that's in the
vicinity of southern california we can't
say they're in la because they're down
in anaheim and if i were to leave for a
seven o'clock start now they're 12 miles
away i'd get there probably tomorrow
yeah what what happens with otani long
term in anaheim because if they're not
going to have a winning team around him
something tells me he's going to get out
of there soon you know it's a
fascinating question because
you know i hate to be like this but
i i never thought it would be this good
to begin with i did not have faith that
the angels were even going to get one
good season out of him where he was
doing both and so like now that again
we're talking about gimmicks again trust
me it's blowing me away what this guy is
doing but i don't necessarily know how
sustainable that is on a good team never
mind a team that completely sucks or
can't seem to get anything going on a
pitching stand front from a pitching
standpoint i don't know man that's a big
question for that franchise because you
can say everything you want about how
great mike trout is my job is not a star
sorry you know what i mean he's a great
player not a star those are two separate
things and so if you're thinking about
how you want to put bucks in the seat
and you're thinking about how you want
to get eyeballs on your franchise i mean
you're not going to get much better than
shohei otani you know we saw him at the
all-star game
the cheers were tremendous i mean
everybody was there to see him when he
jumped out of the excuse me when he fell
out of the uh
home run derby half the stadium left you
know what i mean like this guy is a
legit draw so that's the question
they're gonna have to think about and i
think that's also a question for the
ohtani camp to think about you know
he's been here for a couple seasons he's
got a little bit more under his belt in
terms of understanding what the united
states is about from a a grind
standpoint and i don't know i think that
they're going to have to choose and i i
i'm not going to lie if i'm not trying
to win games and i'm just trying to
choose people to show up to watch i'm
choosing to show it that's what i'm
doing
yankees and white sox tonight out in the
corn in iowa clinton yates joins the
show the yankees i thought were done and
then this night in the bronx this
ominous night where the rain was coming
down a fan threw something at verdugo
and it seemed like the energy the the
vibes around both teams the red sox and
the yankees just changed and went on
different courses the yankees made some
moves the deadline the fact that they
still have a season is remarkable to me
i thought they were done what are your
thoughts on the yankees and and you got
to they got to get a win tonight every
game counts for them down the stretch
they got to get a win tonight and i
don't want to talk bad about my boy
booney but that team is now in playing
for their managers job territory on some
level which always gives a little extra
boost i don't think there's anything
wrong with that level of motivation but
i just don't think that that franchise
is going to look at that team and say
hey homers and strikeouts and no
playoffs what are we doing here and i
just think that they kind of finally
figured it out i mean it takes a while
for these things you know tonight's game
is huge this is also kind of weird too
why tonight's game is a little awkward
you know it's like you're playing a
relatively important division match up
not between two teams in the same
division but within each division these
teams matter
you know in iowa in the middle of the
week so i'm glad to see that this isn't
going to be just another kind of
throwaway baseball game like this they
will be playing hard you know balls out
into the corner are going to make some
difference this isn't just hollywood
movies and james earl jones wearing
suspenders out here in these streets you
know so it'll be a good game tonight and
i think that the yankees
look do i love the way they play
baseball no do i think that the way that
they play baseball can get them to the
playoffs i do
clinton played commissioner for a second
we saw the success of the london games
hopefully tonight goes off well where
would you like to see baseball played
next
um
probably something more akin to like a
negro league situation i'd love to see a
game in mobile alabama at hank aaron
state the stadium named after henry
aaron he just passed away that's that's
the site of his former childhood home
that they moved the museum over to right
there it's in mobile it used to be a
double a park i i would love to see a
game there i mean you know a perfect
opportunity for history
that's actually real not just stuff that
they made up in hollywood now that'd be
amazing and i hope tonight goes off
without a hitch because i love these
kind of games i think it's great to grow
the game it'll be a fun moment it's
really cool you get to touch and be a
part of it man thanks for taking some
time
i appreciate it this has been a fun time
i have not eaten any corn yet i have not
seen dc eddie i have not seen kevin
costner but i did see
my man dwyer who plays his dad
beforehand that was cool good stuff man
enjoy baseball heaven out there in iowa
we appreciate you taking some time all
right guys have a good day clinton yates
the undefeated guy brings it god loves
baseball huh hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here